ja willkommen zum ende des vorprogramms
und zum start des hauptprogramms wir
kommen nach den wirklich wichtigen frage
ich danke meiner vorredner für ihr
engagement
es geht nämlich jetzt sagen warum haben
wir eigentlich so viele etikette warum
haben besonderheit einen deutschen
ethikrat der doch mehr mehr den eindruck
vermittelt es handele sich um eine
ausgelagerte staatliche behörde zur
abdeckung von regierungshandeln wir
haben beispielsweise die vorsitzende
frau brooke die also 2 g klasse findet
bevor es eingeführt worden ist kaum hat
er joakim ich ein interview gegeben in
dem er sagt habe gewisse bedenken was
seine eigene impfung angeht da fährt sie
ihm in die parade und sagt er sei falsch
beraten worden er sollte sich mal auch
schnell impfen lassen jetzt hat sie
gesagt jetzt muss geimpft werden bis was
die spritze hergibt das ist keine
ethische aussage das ist ein moralischer
hochgezüchtet diskurs jetzt eine
befehlsausgabe als kämen sie direkt aus
dem bundeskanzleramt wir haben einen
anderen ethikrat das ist herr henn der
hat schon einmal vorgeschlagen man sich
doch gedanken machen ob man ungeimpfte
überhaupt die lungen behandlung grund
auf der intensivstation er hat ebenfalls
vorgeschlagen vielleicht nicht geimpften
die ausreise aus deutschland in eu
staaten zu verwehren also diese ethik
räte haben eine sehr geringe
demokratische legitimation zieht sind
ein feigenblatt mit der sich die
regierungen schmücken können sie lagern
dadurch verantwortung aus die aber
letzten endes bei der regierung noch bei
der regierung und bei den parlamenten
liegt sie sind teurer sind com
legitimiert sie sind letztlich das was
einmal ein ethikrats mitglied namens
lobt bindestrich hüdepohl
unvorsichtigerweise ausgeplaudert hat
durchaus geplappert hat ich habe es mit
geschrieben er hat gesagt die aufgabe
des ethik rats besteht darin klare
argumente vorzulegen damit die leute
maßnahmen die dann angeordnet werden
müssen von staatswegen nachvollziehen
können das sei die aufgabe der ethik des
ethikrates also argumente liefern damit
viralen bürger sehen dass die regierung
alles richtig macht ich denke es war mal
anders gedacht wir brauchen eine offene
eine öffentliche debatte wir brauchen
eine gute politik was aber nicht
brauchen ist ein ethikrat
alexander ich kann ihnen nur zustimmen
ich würde es aber anders sagen wann wir
brauchen ist ein funktionierenden
ethikrat weil ich muss schon sagen wir
brauchen ja dringend mal ein
gegengewicht die auch mal auf die sorgen
hinweisen und die ethik auch wirklich im
blick hat deswegen ich würde es nur noch
ergänzen wollen super statement um einen
funktionierenden ethikrat man bekommt
natürlich immer die ethik die man
bestellt also geliefert wie bestellt
oder gar nicht nur jemand zulässt genau
wenn ich also vorauswahl mache an
gewissen prominenten an gewissen
schwerpunkten der forschung des sind wir
jetzt auch wieder am sogenannten
expertenrat im bundeskanzleramt von
herrn scholz dann bekomme ich in der
regel auch die expertise die ich gerne
hätte und da wäre es wirklich besser
wenn man die ganze breite abbildet was
ich ganz ganz wichtig ist und da
versagte ein ethikrat ganz besonders
wenn er skepsis delegitimiert skepsis
ist der beginn aller aufklärung ist der
beginn aller freiheit der beginn allen
fortschritts wir müssen uns alle zum
skeptischen bürgern erziehen und da
haben wir also eti geräte die sagen so
sagt von brück zum beispiel wissen alle
einer meinung es gibt eine moralische
pflicht zur impfung aber hier sind sie
haben ja sie haben ja sozusagen
angeteasert jetzt kommt dass das thema
überhaupt des abends ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen also koyang ich kenne weiß
es gibt einen ethikrat aber frau brooke
kenne ihn kenne ich ja schon sehr sehr
inferno muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich
dass man darüber diskutieren kann aber
zumindest als vertreter des parlaments
kann ihnen sagen dass das sozusagen in
der gewichtung der entscheidung ein
aspekt ist von sehr sehr vielen deswegen
glaube ich sollte man das nicht liegt
tatsächlich noch ja sagt ethikrat müsse
sich jetzt aber daher soll das passiert
auch den ethikrat selbst den den er
selber einmal jemand rausgeworfen und
weil sich dieser sozusagen seine
persönliche meinung gelabelt hat sie mit
das ist die meinung des ethikrats waren
einige im ethikrat nicht ganz
einverstanden
also ich will nur sagen ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig ist dass man
verschiedene tatsächlich möglichkeiten
hat sich auch expertise zu bestimmten
themen zu holen aber ich glaube wir
brauchen das nicht so über zu begleiten
das ist also das annehmen sollte eine
art öffentliche mobil um ende des jahres
abgeben für die politik und es wird ein
immenser druck auf diesen ethik hat
ausgeübt und in der geschäftsordnung
steht auch abweichende meinungen werden
nicht dokumentiert das finde ich
unglaublich ich würde eher die ethikrat
so unterstützen und ihm alle
möglichkeiten geben dass er wirklich
frei entscheiden kann und alle
positionen besprechen kann die für ihn
wichtig sind und dann nachher eine
fundierte empfehlungen abzugeben der
druck der momentan auf den ethikrat
ausgelöst wird den halte ich für sehr
ist aber selbst durch den bürger es ist
oder ersetzen durch den bürger ist auch
oder ergänzend ein charmanter
etikettenschwindel verstehen uns ja wir
sollten nicht vergessen dass die
kanzlerin 2011 einen ethikrat eingesetzt
hat um den atomausstieg
intellektuell sozusagen vorzubereiten
der atomausstieg ist eine
wissenschaftliche eine nuklear
wissenschaftlich eine medizinische frage
die ethik schlitter nur am rande eine
rolle bei jeder gelegenheit hole jetzt
ein ethikrat dabei wenn es um sache
entscheidungen geht und da also ein
feigenblatt zu haben die deutschen haben
ja so eine vorliebe für er die st johann
scheidung ist wird nicht so eine sache
entscheidung das ist schon auch eine
ethische entscheidung mit ja aber muss
ich muss sehr straff faktenbasiert sein
sonst kann ich gar nicht die ethik
wirklich voll entfalten lassen ich muss
ja wissen welche auswirkungen die
impfung hat und wenn ich erst die
impfung empfehlen und dann stelle ich
fest der geimpfte trägt das virus auch
weiter dann habe ich eine tolle ethik
entfaltet wenn ich gesagt haben lasst
euch impfen aber ich habe gar keine
wirkung hat aber es ist noch mal ein
echter tätig führt in die irre weil sie
ein höheres intellektuelles und quasi
religiöses auch um mitbringt und das hat
dieser rat gar nicht der trifft ganz
pragmatische politik entscheidung im
politischen vorfeld als berater und als
beratung und dieses aufblasen mit ethik
bringt da eine möglicherweise das hinein
was die großen kirchen an ethischen
schwergewicht langsam leider verlieren
auch aus eigenem verschulden aber wie
gesagt noch mal lob hüdepohl hat gesagt
unsere aufgabe muss ich mir noch mal
notieren
also ein mitglied das im deutschen
ethikrat gesagt unsere aufgabe ist nicht
argumente zu liefern und damit maßnahmen
die die regierung getroffen hat von der
bevölkerung verstanden werden also das
ist für mich also das hat für mich nicht
mit skepsis nicht mit aussehen aber erst
einmal pause macht nein da ist noch
alles drin der erst noch drin er soll ja
natürlich wir bleiben also ich finde wir
müssen wirklich ständig und zu
unterhalten wir haben eine öffentliche
spaltung wir haben also einem eliten
problem vielleicht auch da müssen wir
uns gedanken machen wie reden wir
miteinander wie entlassen wir an den
tisch und dann dürfen wir einfach
skepsis nicht die familien und das ist
mein problem
ethikrat soll empfehlungen abgeben zur
einführung der allgemeinen impfpflicht
ich möchte noch mal sagen wer hat denn
jetzt momentan zu corona überhaupt eine
impfpflicht das ist turkmenistan
tadschikistan und der vatikan und
demnächst deutschland ja super also man
muss sich doch wirklich mal auf ich bin
wirklich neugierig was erich frank
empfiehlt er wird es im film weil ich so
ist er schon auch spannend weil aus
unserer eigenen geschichte ist bekannt
dass wir mehr gute erfahrungen gemacht
haben mit mit imf angeboten diphtherie
90 in unserer geschichte an po und bei
brocken gab es eine impfpflicht und da
war die die impfquote zwischen 60 und 80
prozent das heißt die impfpflicht löst
in der bevölkerung was aus und diese
reaktion ist angst und dieser zwang auch
protest ich glaube wir werden viel mehr
damit erreichen wenn wir in der weise
wie wir jetzt vorgehen die anreize
steigern und natürlich alternative
impfstoffe auf den markt bringen weil
ich glaube dass dezimiert auch noch mal
die impfskepsis
skeptiker erheblich und dann kommen wir
weg von dieser debatte dass der staat
etwas den menschen aufzwingen möchte um
einen einen schaden von ihm abzuwenden
und dieses aufzwingen wird als
unangenehm erlebt ich möchte nicht dass
der staat über meine gesundheit
entscheidet und da kenne ich auch viele
ärzte die sagen das geht tatsächlich ein
schritt zu weit das ist eine rote linie
die darüber scheint der punkt ist
einfach der ethikrat wird entscheiden
aber egal wir entscheiden wird er wird
einfach nicht mehr als unabhängiges
gremium wahrgenommen das ist das problem
wenn ich eigentlich ethikrat anderthalb
jahre den ethischen geleitschutz für
regierungshandeln gebe alles in allem
ist dann auch kann ich einfach nicht
erwarten dass das urteil als vollkommen
unabhängig objektiv wahrgenommen ich
muss unterbrechen aber dafür würde ich
dir das schlusswort wagen
geilen satz heute wir sollten dies jetzt
ist nicht die familien sehr schön
dementsprechend der schlusssatz gehört
die